dans d'autres nouvelles, le CDC reçoit des
rapports sur une éventuelle épidémie de grippe à
San Francisco, mais les responsables disent qu'ils
ne sont pas connectés, l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé souhaite maintenant des directives concernant l'
incident du virus mortel répertoriant
divers antiviraux, mais en ce moment,
ils appellent maintenant cela  une véritable pandémie
cinq ans plus tard toujours pas de remède pas de remède la
dame beaucoup de ces soudains en nous dans le
seul ont assez de ressources pour se
nourrir un
autre gouvernement s'effondre alors que l'
eau potable
merci pendant 10 ans en raison de l'
extrémité de la crise de la grippe simienne  toutes
les fonctions régulières du gouvernement ont été
suspendues indéfiniment attention en raison de
l'extrême crise de la grippe simienne
toutes les fonctions régulières du gouvernement ont
été suspendues
vous